welcome to the quick start tutorial for
bigquery google cloud's large-scale data
warehouse for storage and analysis
in this video we're going to walk
through how to analyze data stored in
bigquery using the bq command line tool
to start visit console.cloud.google.com
to open the google cloud console this
web portal allows you to manage and
explore your cloud resources directly
from a browser
create a new project by clicking the
project viewer button at the top of your
screen
once it's ready you'll get a
notification saying so click the
notifications icon and then click select
project to open your new project
next activate cloud shell by clicking
its icon to the right of the search bar
cloud shell is an online development
environment that comes pre-loaded with
helpful tools for interacting with your
cloud resources
once it launches click the maximize
button to increase the size of the cloud
shell terminal
now you'll use the bq command line tool
to explore one of the sample tables
provided in bigquery the shakespeare
table which contains an entry for every
word in every shakespeare play
you can use the bqshow command to
display information about the table
type bqshow plus the table reference in
the command prompt
if prompted make sure to click authorize
to authorize cloud shell to make api
calls
you will then see information about the
table returned including the schema and
size
you can learn more about how to use the
bq command line tool by typing in bq
help
you can also view information about a
specific command
here we can ask for information about
the bquery command now let's run an sql
query over the shakespeare table using
the bq query command
this query which is available following
the link in the description below
calculates how many times the substring
reason appears in shakespeare's
works the output shows that while
raisins appears once the raisin
substring also appears in words like
praising and raising
we can also query to see how many times
the substring huzza appears
since the substring does not appear in
shakespeare's works no results are
returned
now let's create a new table and place
it in a new data set
our sample data will come from the u.s
social security administration and
contains about seven megabytes of data
about popular baby names
first visit the link in the description
below and download the baby names zip
file to your local device
open the file
yob2010.txt to see what it looks like it
contains comma separated values for
three columns
name sex and number of children with
that name
next
upload the
yob2010.txc file from your local device
to cloud shell
using the three dotted more menu you can
confirm that the file was successfully
uploaded to the cloud shell environment
by running ls
run bqls to check whether your project
has existing data sets
now we can run the bqmk command to
create a new data set called baby names
for our own project
if we run bqls again we can see that our
new data set appears as part of our
project
in the baby names dataset that you
created use the bqload command to load
your source file yob2010.txc
into a new table called names2010
this command creates a table and loads
data in a single step you can provide
the data set id
table id
source and schema
once the upload is complete confirm that
the table now appears in the data set by
running bqls
names
you can also view the table schema by
running bqshow babynames.names2010.
now that the table is loaded we can run
some queries on the data again using the
bq query command
for example this query returns the most
popular girls names
and this one returns some unusual boys
names
now that you've successfully run your
queries make sure to complete a few
quick cleanup steps
to avoid incurring storage charges to
your google cloud account for the
resources used in this quick start
run this bqrm command and confirm the
delete command by typing in y
to finish cleanup type rmyob2010.txt
to remove the file that you uploaded to
your cloud shell environment
and that's it you're now equipped to run
queries and load data using the bq
command line tool
make sure to check out the rest of our
bigquery documentation at
cloud.google.com
bigquery docs to learn more about how to
use bigquery to gain insights about your
data
[Music]
you